hey sorry I I just noticed you were
hanging this on your door knob you're
probably going to want to keep that in
the room where it's safe yeah I know
that's why I put it on the door yeah
hanging out there in the open all
willy-nilly like a purse dangling from
an old woman's frail flabby arm maybe
one Wednesday afternoon a young man down
on his luck and out of option snatches
it then he waits for the heat to blow
over posing as a hotel manager for a few
months when lo and behold he looks in
the bag it's not full of money it's full
of heart hard candy and birth
control who is she
right did you rob an old
lady
no you want to buy some birth
control
no